I have never seen an animated movie like
this in my life this is a style of
animation heaven named to you guys oh
gosh you know the marketing team at Sony
asked us this and we struck out about a
year ago it's a new thing that hasn't
been done I mean from the very beginning
we were like can we make a movie that
feels like you're walking inside of a
comic book
and everybody at Sony or Justin Thompson
the production designer Danny Damien was
the effects supervisor were like yes but
it's not gonna be easy and it took us
years to figure out the process of both
CG and 2d hand-drawn animation and all
of these like comic book textures and
designs woven in into something that
feels like every frame is a painting I
have a pitch yeah
cinnamon oh I like it yeah like like
like it's like it's very high it's very
hard but it was really hard please let's
brush out this with this new style of
animation is there anything new that's
added to the process whether it's a new
job position a new tool you didn't have
before anything like that well we we
with art someone at our team had to
write new software and and we kept
saying we want you to break the systems
and want the server to meltdown I want
people to like not know how to use these
tools anymore
and we succeed right and even like the
lighting department was making lighting
that was halftone dots and having how do
you figure out how that moves in three
dimensions and shadows that were hash
mark sort of things and textures that
were paintings and every step of the way
every step of the process like the hair
had to be stylized the cloth had to have
a
a limited comic-book style movement
everybody in each department was
inventing a new process along the way so
there wasn't a chapter this thing that
wasn't trying to shake things up so you
guys pretty much already announced that
we're gonna get more of these types of
movies given how long it takes to
animate such little bits of this
community to any other I mean what
should people expect in terms of a
timeline because I imagine a lot of time
it's gonna have to go into those new
movies well it's still really early and
you know the movie hasn't come out yet
so we're not gonna count any chickens at
one point but not doing no or not I was
thank you chicken counting but but but
obviously the idea of the multiverse
opens up a lot of possibilities infinite
you might say possibilities so it's
really exciting to think about what
could it be
and there are a lot of things that
really are engaging to us but it's you
know it's still really early I really
can't stop thinking about all the
possibilities especially because the
idea of anyone can wear the mask it's
such a throwaway line that said or a
little button at the end it's something
that kind of reverberates throughout the
entire film and that gets seared in your
brain but really can't stop thinking
about possibilities oh that's great
that's exactly I was laughs success
count those chickens right yes so he's
only a little bit about assembling at
the team of directors here but we have
three directors some haven't worked on
the feature some have had different
positions on an animated movie before
what made the three of them the right
group well you know they this is such a
gargantuan task you need people with all
kinds of different superpowers and each
of those guys you know has something to
offer that we don't know how to do the
performances that bobbers Katie put
together with these characters are just
like I put it up against anything that
anybody is doing they're so human
they're funny they're they've got so
much personality and and and like all
those guys like they all have soul and
and and at anytime you would watch the
reels that even a scene that like I
wrote it and was way too long and it
didn't work like you would watch and be
like oh they feel for these people there
they're like diving into the
idiosyncrasies and
and the observation of each of them so
you know they're all really ambitious
that's the thing that ties them together
and they recognize that one another has
you know yeah it has I have all of these
strains and Peter is an amazing artist
and and choreographer of action in a way
that that is so easy to understand
what's happening and you never lose
sight of the goal and its really
inventive and stylish and he was just
like a rock throughout the whole process
also a secret sweetheart
yeah who's really sensitive and thinking
about like that little thing that's
gonna make you engage even deeper with
the picture and Rodney was a guy that
we've worked with many times in the past
we worked with him on 22 Jump Street and
lots of other things and he was
something that we brought in to help out
with a script while we were extra busy
and and then he was so helpful and so
got what we were all going for that we
were like and thought that we could aim
higher yeah we were like well would you
like to come join the party and he was
like yeah let's do it
and and it was a little bit
untraditional but that's what this movie
is about a bunch of people coming
together towards a common goal and
they're all different and they all says
we all agreed on the kind of movie we
wanted to make it made it work yeah it
can imagine it going horribly wrong if
people only might make a gritty
coalminer drama yeah oh no take such big
swings and big risks for you one little
thing could have gone wrong and it
wouldn't have come together as well but
everything is just firing at peak levels
so well but we know you guys we know the
three directors and we know all of the
wonderful actors who voice these
characters but I'm always curious to
hear about an unsung hero on an animated
movie because there's so many different
departments and so many people that work
on these things so if you had to name
one for this production who well I think
it's got to be Justin Thompson yeah
because you know Justin was the first
call that we made you know before we
even started coming up with the story
and he's a production designer we worked
with cloudy and and the sequel
and he just knows in his bones what this
movie looks like and and he elevated
every step that they took in it you know
he was pushing as hard as any of us
right and we were like we wanted to
break learn to go as far as you possibly
can learn to feel like nothing you ever
seen before and he was like well I'm
gonna take it even farther it was it was
really inspiring to see and how much
passion he brought to it and everybody I
mean there's hundreds of people working
on this thing and everybody contributed
creatively it was I mean like like like
even in the DI sweet like Justin and
Natasha did at the end just to like
sweeten everything and make sure that
the the amount of color of the movie
escalates I mean there's just like a lot
of fine detail in it
right down to there like the sound mix
like the the sound mix is so sensitive
it's super loud and super quiet the
dynamics are out of control and and it
just went that way through every
department to wrap up we do a show on
collider called collider fyc where we
get to celebrate all the things we're
going to be talking about through award
season and again you don't want to count
chickens but we're constantly talking
about what the definition of an Oscar
movie is what it means just in general
but also to you personally so I wanted
to pose that question to you guys what
is the term Oscar Moby mean to you I
mean I think that the at its best you
know Oscar celebrates excellence and
things that resonate with people and
mean something to them you know and I
don't I think that transcends genre and
and it's if you know you know when you
see it when you walk out of the theater
and you're really thrilled yeah and I
can get kind of crazy but at the end of
the day there's something kind of cool
about people getting together and say
hey let's celebrate movies that are that
are really special and have something
something new to say yeah the remarkable
thing about it is whether like whether
you agree or disagree with it
comes you have a national sometimes
international conversation about art
that lasts months that's like amazing
[Music]